I consider that it would be foolish for
me to write about Charlemagne's birth
and childhood or even about his boyhood
for nothing is set down in writing about
this and nobody can be found still alive
who claims to have any personal
knowledge of these matters I have
therefore decided to leave out what is
not really known and to move on to his
deeds and habits and the other aspects
of his life which need explanation and
elaboration first of all I shall
describe his achievements at home and
abroad then his personal habits and
enthusiasms then the way in which he
administered his kingdom and last of all
his death omitting from all this nothing
which ought to be known or indeed which
is worthy of being recorded
of all the wars which Charlemagne waged
the first which he ever undertook was
one against Aquitaine which had been
begun by his father but not brought to a
proper conclusion he thought that it
would be soon over he began it while his
brother Carlo man was still alive and
even went so far as to ask his brother
for help
Carlo man did not give him the promised
support nevertheless Charlemagne pressed
on energetically with the expedition
which he had put into the field refusing
to withdraw from a campaign already
started or to abandon a task once
undertaken in the end with no small
perseverance and continued effort he
brought to complete fruition what he was
striving to achieve after the death of
wife are hung old had attempted to
occupy Aquitaine and to renew a wall
which was almost over but Charlemagne
forced him to evacuate the territory and
flee to Gascony determined as he was not
to let Honnold find refuge there
Charlemagne crossed the river Garonne
and sent messages to Lupus Duke of the
Gaskins to order him to surrender the
fugitive Charlemagne's threatened to
declare war on lupus too if he did not
do as he was ordered quickly
lupus well in a sensible decision not
only did he surrender Honnold but he
also submitted himself and the province
over which he ruled to Charlemagne's
suzerainty
[Music]
once matters were settled in Aquitaine
and this particular war was finished and
now that his partner on the throne had
been withdrawn from the anxieties of
this world Charlemagne next fought a war
against the longer bards he undertook
this at the request of Hadrian bishop of
the city of Rome who first asked and
then begged him to do so this war too
had been started in the first instance
by Charlemagne's father at the request
of Pope Stephen but in the most
difficult circumstances for certain of
the Frankish leaders whom Pepin the
short was accustomed to consult was so
opposed to his wishes that they openly
announced their determination to desert
their King and return home
despite this Pepin declared war on King
haste off and brought this war to a
rapid completion although the reason for
him undertaking this war was similar to
that which had inspired his father and
indeed identical it is clear that
Charlemagne fought it with much more
energy and brought it to a different
conclusion after besieging pavia for a
few days Pepin forced herself to give
hostages to restore the towns and
fortresses which he had taken from the
Romans and to swear an oath on the holy
sacrament that he would not try to
regain what he had surrendered once
Charlemagne on the other hand had taken
over the war he did not stop until he
had warned the Siderius down by a long
siege and had received his surrender he
forced a dogus the son of Desiderius on
whom the hopes of everyone seemed to
center to go into exile not merely from
his father's kingdom but indeed from
Italy itself he restored to the Romans
everything which had been taken from
them he crushed a revolt started by rot
gout the Duke of Friuli subjected the
whole of Italy to his own domination and
made his
son pepid king of the territory which he
had conquered
[Applause]
at this point I really should explain
how difficult Charlemagne found the
crossing of the Alps when he came to
enter Italy and after what effort on the
part of the Franks the pathless ridges
of the mountains were traversed and the
rocks which rid themselves up to the sky
and the abrupt abysus but in this
present work I am determined to offer
the modern reader a description of
Charlemagne's way of life and not the
day-to-day details of his Wars the
outcome of this conflict was that Italy
was subdued King Darius was carried off
into exile for the remainder of his life
his son at algis was expelled from Italy
and everything stolen by the law about
Kings was restored to Hadrian the ruler
of the Church of Rome
[Music]